[Music]
if you want a glimpse of Marie Curie's
manuscripts you'll have to sign a waiver
and put on protective gear to shield
yourself from radiation contamination
Madame Curie's remains two were interred
in a lead-lined coffin keeping the
radiation that was the heart of her
research and likely the cause of her
death
well-contained growing up in Warsaw in
Russian occupied Poland the young Marie
originally named Maria Sklodowska was a
brilliant student but she faced some
challenging barriers as a woman she was
barred from pursuing higher education so
in an act of defiance Marie enrolled in
the floating University a secret
institution that provided clandestine
education to Polish youth by saving
money and working as a governess and
tutor she eventually was able to move to
Paris to study at the reputed Sorbonne
there Marie earned both the physics and
mathematics degree surviving largely on
bread and tea and sometimes fainting
from near starvation in Paris Marie met
the physicist Pierre Curie who shared
his lab and his heart with her but she
longed to be back in Poland upon her
return to Warsaw though she found that
securing an academic position as a woman
remained a challenge all was not lost
back in Paris the lovelorn Pierre was
waiting and the pair quickly married and
became a formidable scientific team
another physicists work sparked Marie
Curie's interest in 1896 on Rebecca L
discovered that uranium spontaneously
emitted a mysterious x-ray like
radiation that could interact with
photographic film Curie soon found that
the element thorium emitted similar
radiation most importantly the strength
of the radiation depended solely on the
elements quantity and was not affected
by physical or chemical changes this led
her to conclude that radiation was
coming from something fundamental within
the atoms of each element the idea was
radical and helped to disprove the
long-standing model of atoms as
indivisible objects next by focusing on
a super radioactive ore called
pitchblende
the curious realized that uranium alone
couldn't be creating all the radiation
so were there other radioactive elements
that might be responsible in 1898 they
reported two new elements polonium named
for Maria's native Poland and radium the
Latin word for Rhea they also coined the
term radioactivity along the way by 1902
the Curie's had extracted a tenth of a
gram of pure radium chloride salt from
several tons of pitchblende an
incredible feat at the time later that
year Pierre Curie and on Reba Carell
were nominated for the Nobel Prize in
Physics but Marie was overlooked
Pierre took a stand in support of his
wife's well-earned recognition and so
both of the Curie's and Becker all
shared the 1903 Nobel Prize making Marie
Curie the first female Nobel laureate
well funded and well respected the
Curie's were on a roll but tragedy
struck in 1906 when Pierre was crushed
by a horse-drawn cart as he crossed a
busy intersection Marie devastated
immersed herself in her research and
took over Pierre's teaching position at
the Sorbonne becoming the school's first
female professor her solo work was
fruitful in 1911 she won yet another
Nobel this time in chemistry for her
earlier discovery of radium and polonium
and her extraction and analysis of pure
radium and its compounds this made her
the first and to this date only person
to win Nobel prizes in two different
Sciences professor Curie put her
discoveries to work changing the
landscape of medical research and
treatments she opened mobile radiology
units during World War one and
investigated radiations effects on
tumors
however these benefits to humanity may
have come at a high personal cost Curie
died in 1934 of a bone-marrow disease
which many today think was caused by her
radiation exposure Marie Curie's
revolutionary research laid the
groundwork for our understanding of
physic
and chemistry blazing trails in oncology
technology medicine and nuclear physics
to name a few for good or ill her
discoveries in radiation launched a new
era unearthing some of Sciences greatest
secrets
[Music]
you